all right I think it's time I will
volunteer
Americans went on you know stay in one
thing so
uh
thank you
so um
I'll talk about symmetries
um I will give you an idea of how
symmetries are are can be used in in sub
and specifically about uh proofs for
showing that techniques such as symmetry
braking are actually correct how you can
prove it
and since this is about bringing
theoreticians and practitioners together
I tried to add some challenges in here
for the theory people and some some meat
for the practitioners and one of the
things that I'm doing is well
um for theoreticians MP is a difficult
problem practitioners came along and
they solved it
um
now what I noticed the Solomon the
theory slide says there's always this
nice pictures that all the different
proof systems and on the top there's
extended trigger and there's nothing
Beyond
and um I'll show you a rule dominance
rule it's not clear that this can be
simulated by extended trigger this is a
question to be resolved by the
theoreticians but server the
it's implemented in a practical proof
system so the practitioners come along
and they say well
you have this nice picture let's well
forget about it let's go higher or let's
try and um so there's a I think on my
last slide there's a concrete it's a
Concrete challenge for you guys the
result
um but so
um I'll talk about symmetries I said I
will not explain what start solving is
about I will not have to convince you
any more of why you need proof vlogging
I think the previous speakers today I
don't know uh very good job at uh
convincing you over that but I'm
interested in symmetries interested in
symmetries and they're very simple
things there are permutations of
literals
the two properties
um on the one hand if they map the
negation of an atom to the negation of
um what they might be atom to so they
they commute to negation they respect
negation and they preserve the formula
so if I apply the Symmetry to
um my CNF then I get the same CNF again
um these are also called this condition
is also called often a syntactic
symmetries you can go beyond that but in
practice
um people usually focus on syntactic
symmetries yes
my decrease
so if we apply Sigma here we get exactly
the same formula again so nothing
changes but what we're gonna do is we're
gonna add later on extract roses and
bring symmetry that remove some
symptomatic Solutions
okay
um so very small example there's a
formula here a CNF this is how I denote
my symmetries
um as a is mapped to b b is mapped to
the negation of C so you cannot
um atoms to literals negative C is map
to D and then back to a and at the same
time X and Y are swapped and then of
course because the negation has to be
respected so more things happen
I claim this is a symmetry of f if you
want to check this you apply the
Symmetry replacing
um a by B and so on you get this and you
can see the color the colors code that
this is exactly the same formula okay so
nothing special happening here
um symmetric problems sometimes they are
problematic for cdcl solvers
um well we've seen enough examples of
pigeon holes so we all know that
um so the question is what can we do
with them what can we do with symmetric
problems
um I'll first give a little bit of an
overview of different methods to handle
symmetries in in uh in sub and then I'll
explain to you what um how we solve this
problem in in very PB I'll give a quick
introduction to the very PB proof system
I will not go too much into detail about
the Symmetry breaking but I have more
backup slides and actual slides if you
are interested in that we can talk about
it for a long time
and I'll conclude
so
um symmetry in set
um so people who are at the actual uh
might have seen the slide already uh
there's
an overlap between the presentation of
them but I'll I'll give in an update
there's there's updates in there so uh
novel things first of all I will
categorize symmetry handling methods
into two categories static these are
things I think preprocessors that you
can combine with any solver and dynamic
that's deep integration in the solver
doing things during search
um and on the other hand I have a
characterization in Breaking methods so
methods that can actually remove
Solutions and non-breaking methods these
are methods that preserve all solutions
but still do small smart things with the
symmetries anyway
um the
in a certain sense simplest approach is
static symmetry breaking you just have a
um oh yeah so there was a on previous
slides
there are no non-breaking static methods
as far as I know so no
well because statically what you can do
basically is you can eliminate Solutions
somehow
um or change your set of solutions but
this kind of methods doesn't exist uh
the best of my knowledge the simplest
type of methods I would say are static
symmetry breaking methods so
preprocessors that add new Clauses to
eliminate certain Solutions
preferably you only keep one solution
um
one candidate of each equivalence Clause
but it's not easy to achieve and they
started a long time ago it's chatter and
break it is an uh an improvement that we
developed on top of shutter and I'll
tell a little bit of a story here
um
when we were developing break it
um well actually before we were
developing Break It We were working on
methods that will appear somewhere here
and shutter was constantly outperforming
us on certain uh instances in particular
on digital problems
and it was always breaking the problem
completely and this was
wonderful
um but we
wondered why why is it working so well
and
why when we slightly change the problem
does it break and the slightly changing
here only boiled down to changing the
variable order so we were not even
really changing the problem just
different variable ordering and it broke
completely
um and we analyzed this so we started
from a y question
so might call this science
um we started from a y question and we
said okay what's what's really going on
and it turned out that
um the um what was showing there was
something known as row symmetries and
constraint programming that were
occurring
um it was known there that that if you
have the right type of symmetries and
the right structure in your symmetry
group and the right order on the
variables if these two match
then you can break a group completely
with just a very small number of
generators yeah but if you take the
wrong variable ordering
then this this then you take the same
generators and you just post like little
leader constraints as well this uh this
doesn't work anymore so this is how we
got from from shutter to break that's
the main Improvement where we're
actually detecting the structure and
making sure everything is aligned the
order the generators and the well the
order and the generators these are the
most important things
um so the idea is simple
namely
um add new Clauses that exclude
um a cement an assignment Alpha if it's
symmetric variant is smaller
lexicographically smaller given some
Modern variables that's the the core
idea of these methods
then there are
um Dynamic braking methods
um the idea of local symmetry breaking
is very similar to This Global symmetry
breaking but on sub formulas after some
choices have been made
um methods are two asymmetric branching
they don't really add extra Clauses but
they branch in some asymmetric way
um and then there's effective symmetry
breaking and actually also submodal
symmetries and submar Locus which have a
sort of propagator that will add some
symmetry breaking methods
um on the fly during search when it
seems to be useful for the solver for
instance when these would propagate so
this this add new Clauses when they
would propagate so you're not adding
gigantically many Clauses up front
you're just doing it when they're useful
but that's the core idea
and then there's Dynamic uh non-breaking
methods
and most of them fall under the category
of symmetric learning which is well your
subsolver is learning lots of useful
things it's learning new Clauses all the
time
we know the original instance was was
symmetric
if your subsolver is not doing crazy
things say is only learning implied
clauses
then actually if you just take the
symmetric variant of one of these
implied Clauses it's again implied
so let's add these as well
and there's many different methods the
point is you you can again not add all
of them to the way too many so they
mostly differ in when they deem Applause
to be interesting enough to add to the
solar
and then there's also methods that
combine these two techniques combine
symmetry breaking sometimes and and then
symmetry propagation which is one of the
symmetric learning methods
um in other types
um
so I promise you to talk about proofs
so proofs for symmetry breaking and for
static symmetry breaking there is direct
proof logging and it works very well for
certain types of symmetries it doesn't
work for the general type of symmetries
that I that I showed you before
um and since recently we have proof
vlogging with very PB and this works in
the full generality for the static
symmetry breaking
and when I presented this adage tool I
said well
this also seems to be applicable to
Dynamic symmetry braking so uh symmetry
breaking so not the symmetric learning
methods I'll come back to those later
um
this was a bit unsatisfactory to make
these claims here without dusting it so
after that
um when I went back to Brussels I uh
gave my master student one of the master
students in the course I'm teaching as
this project assignment he he was
supposed to do this Dynamic symmetry
braking and um so it worked out so
we we have a working version now of
these effective symmetry breaking
predicates
um and the nice thing is
he had kind of I mean he's a very good
student but he had a difficult job in
getting it to work completely and the
reason turned out in the end that there
were one or two bucks in the
implementation that were messing up is
proofs so we and when I say one or two
um one of them we're not really sure yet
that it can actually trigger into
into breaking a concrete instance but
the other one we have confirmed that
this is the other one was just
um some extra condition that was not
present in the in the paper that was
added there and we can we can break we
know how to break it how to make the
silver fail there so
um
so this again shows the the benefit of
um of adding this type of proof vlogging
but it also
um shows that it's I mean once these
techniques are out there it's not too
hard this is a six credit uh course that
he was following of which 25 was this
project assignment so it he couldn't
have spent weeks and weeks and weeks on
it and they took a silver and it just
added existing silver he added it and it
works out with very Improvement so this
was this was very nice that he was a
very good student I don't think any
student can do it
um
another symmetric learning their
um there's also quite recently there's
proof logging for it
um there's it's in a certain sense you
could say it's a bit a special purpose
it has a special
um
it has knowledge of what symmetries are
and it gets and its rules to derive
symmetries and to apply them so it's
really focused tailored towards the
symmetric towards um
using symmetries on the other end Terry
PB as I'll show you the rules doesn't
know about symmetries the only thing
about it knows of is
um rules similar to
um d-ret and it has Witnesses in there
which are slight generalizations of of
um assignments but I'll come back to
that
um so it's still an open question could
we do this with specifically without
without a specific rule that needs to
know about synergies it's sort of a more
General proof system
um so very big
um so it's in a lot of proof systems I
think
um in the more practical talks they've
all been
um closer we've also seen these Theory
overview that there's lots of other
things and one of the um group systems
you might have seen there is cutting
planes this is what therapy Builds on
for my explanation now it's not super
important that it's built some on
cutting planes
um but I'll introduce it anyway
and it extends cutting planes with
strengthening rules that are similar to
propagation redundancy or um or a red
rule for instance
but crucially for us for the Symmetry
braking we can reason with optimization
problems because what I'm going to do by
the end of this presentation I'm going
to be pretending to solve an
optimization problem
do proof vlogging that's clearly correct
in the context of this optimization
problem
and then conclude that well if there if
there are no Optimal Solutions there are
no Solutions
and if you want to know a lot of details
about the Checker you can see 7. these
are actually the the documentation we
submitted to the sub competition uh is
even more up to date so I should have
update this
so through the Boolean constraints are
integer linear constraints over zero one
variables we've got literals as before
we got variables that they tell you zero
which is false or one which is true
nothing new here and cutting planes
super simple the only did this in high
school yeah you've got a bunch of
inequalities you're allowed to add them
up
and if you have a number an integer
number that's greater than or equal to a
rational number you're allowed to round
this one up that's cutting planes
now um I said we're going to extend this
cutting planes with redundant redundancy
rules and we've seen the definition of
redundance so that well you're all it's
okay to add it you're not going to be
eliminating all solutions
um
we've seen we've seen red already we've
seen PR
and we slightly extended this to the
Boolean setting this is just um I mean
the rule is the same you've got a
formula you've got the negation of a
constraint if you can show that from
your formula and the negation of a
constraint it follows that the formula
and the constraint is satisfied after
patching it up with um the witness then
you're happy and the way to think about
this is this witness here it's slightly
more General than the assignment in in a
marine stock it's allowed to map
um variables not just to zero or one
it's not just an assignment but two
other literals and you can view this as
a way to to
um to patch up Solutions so think of
this one here this this uh this witness
as a way to patch up Solutions so you
have a solution you can replace it by
Alpha composed with uh this um this
witness and the other way you can view
it is as a way to patch up foremost
namely just replace every everything in
here by whatever it's not to yeah so
that's two views and these two views are
consistent in the sense that well a
certain assignment satisfies a patched
up formula even only if the patched up
assignment satisfies the original
formula
so what this rule is telling me is that
if I have a solution for the formula
that violates C then the patched up
assignment satisfies F and C so that's
that's the essence of of
um of the rule as the essence of
propagation redundancy that's the
essence of red they just differ in how
they are allowed patching
um
so I don't need to give this proof
schedule because it's basically the same
if you want to prove that any of these
rules is correct it's basically the same
but I told you we were gonna uh switch
to optimization problems and for
optimization problems you have to be
slightly more careful
um so what they are is we we're doing
pseudo Boolean optimization so I'm
assuming that I have some objective
given this is again just um a linear
combination of literals and
the proofs the notion of proofs will
slide and it changed were approve of
optimality will be well first of all
here's a solution
with a certain objective value and there
will be a proof that you cannot have any
better Solutions
this is well you can rewrite this
um
so this spoiler I already gave earlier
than it's saying so here so that we can
always if we have a decision problem
it's okay to just switch to an
optimization perspective
so we can always invent a new objective
and pretend that we're optimizing that
and the rules that are consistent with
that Preserve at least you know one
optimal solution if there is one and if
we can then find that there are no
Optimal Solutions then there was no
solution in the first place
so if you're doing proof logging for
optimization problems uh so you need to
be a bit careful about what you're doing
um you don't have to preserve at least
one solution but you have to not have to
preserve at least one optimal solution
so every uh if you want to add a clause
to say that it's redundant it must
Preserve at least one optimal solution
you definitely want to exclude any type
of types of rules that would just
eliminate all Optimal Solutions but keep
keep a very bad one instead
standard cutting plane rules they're
okay because they can only derive
implies implied constraints so nothing
can go wrong there
um
what we're gonna do is as soon as we
find the solution we allow deriving an
objective improving constraint that says
from now on I'm looking for better
Solutions because remember the proof
consists of two parts
claiming here's the solution and showing
there's no better solution so if you
think of this as a linear sub and sub
search you're allowed to log Solutions
now and then and every time you log
Solutions you get a model improving or
objective improving constraint and in
the end you're going to be able to show
unsought from that constraint showing
that there is no better solution
and our redundance rule must not destroy
good Solutions so we talked about this
patching up
what I now want to ensure is that when
I'm patching up my solution doesn't be
Converse so that the patched up solution
is as least as good as the original
solution remember we're minimizing these
objective here
um so that's the only change you need to
to bring this rule to the optimization
set yeah
but what we noticed as well is that
um
um oh yeah so okay
um here so that we can be a bit more
aggressive
um in case we have a very good witness
so a very good way of patching up namely
if you have a very good way of patching
up think optimization setting if you're
a witness strictly improves your
Solutions
then you don't even need to prove that c
will hold in the patched up assignment
so
um here at this and we call this a
dominance Rule and this is the one that
lies at the at the core of uh the way we
can do symmetry breaking very
efficiently namely
um so what this is saying now is if I
have an assignment that satisfies my
formula but not a constraint I would
like to add
and then I patch it up then I still have
something that satisfies the formula and
has a strictly better objective and I'm
not even mentioning the new constraint
here so I don't need to prove anything
about a new constraint
um so why why does this work well
um if I have such an assignment it
satisfies us with falsifies d then I can
Patch It Up
and after patching it up I get a
strictly better one
and
um either this one satisfies so it
definitely satisfies F because of this
here and either it satisfies D or it
violates d one of the two must be there
if it satisfies the I'm happy because
then I didn't destroy
um then this Alpha wasn't an optimal
solution in the first place so it's okay
to destroy it
um but if it's um doesn't satisfy D I
can just apply the rule again I can just
patch that one up again and I get
again a strictly better one
and if I keep on doing this
I cannot keep on getting infinitely many
uh there's only a finite number of
assignments so in the end this should
end somewhere and they should stop this
decreasing signals should stop at some
point so
what this is giving us is this um
this way of patching up this witness is
not just showing us how to get to a
solution how to patch up our Solutions
immediately that is giving us an
indirect way of fetching up Solutions
yeah
yeah and and this is very useful
um so you can keep on going keep on
going in the end we'll find we'll find a
solution
um and why is this very useful well
because you cannot just do this once you
can do this multiple times in a way that
um
for all of your previously derived
constraints
you you don't have to prove anything
about them so it's not just one proof
obligation I'm dropping here and saying
I don't care what I derived before as
long as I can go strictly down in my
objectives it's fine
so
um you can think why is this sound and
it's well it requires a bit more time
than uh I'm not gonna do this here in
the presentation but you can actually
repeat the same proof over and over
again in some sort of uh nested way or
you can Reason by contradiction there's
multiple ways to prove this but it in
the end uh it is sound meaning that
whatever I derived before it's not gonna
hinder derivations I do now and this is
overcoming one of the problems that the
direct symmetry breaking
um had to well work around in certain
ways even for for quite simple
symmetries already namely that they all
interact yeah well here what we now have
is that this optimization term it's
giving us a way to coordinate I'm I'm by
switching to this optimization
perspective I get some sort of
coordination that whatever I'm do okay I
do if I do this if I use these strange
rules that have strictly decreasing
objectives it will always be with
respect to the same objective
and this this is this turned out to be
very handy
there's more extensions
um in our paper if you're careful it's
even possible to switch between orders
uh during the same proof
um but I will not give these details
here
yeah
going back to the simpler version of
this
um
I guess in that in case you gave this
this intuition then oh I can iterate
Omega in order to find a fix up that
actually meets the original definition
of acceptable is that is that actually
technically correct and if it is can you
come up with a similar statement for the
more complex form of this rule which is
from Omega I can build uh an Omega Prime
that's acceptable not just under D but
under all the D that I was ignoring yes
so it's indeed correct so if you apply
Omega here often enough and eventually
you'll get to a solution yeah and you
could actually go back through your
proof and apply all the omegas often
enough to get to a solution and if you
do if you do this carefully but it's the
Reconstruction might be
um some work but if you do this
carefully you can get there yes okay I
guess that's telling us really that like
the original rule like it might be hard
to find the Omega but the original rule
is somehow like complete here it's just
as powerful as this rule
um
and what do you mean by so are you
saying this rule is
the fnd on the right
with f and D on the right
no because no because your Omega is not
fixed your Omega might depend on your uh
your uh so yeah so it's not like I can
if I know I have to apply Omega seven
times yeah depending on Alpha I love to
play Omega a different number of times
and then if you go to the next slide
it's you have to apply all these omegas
you basically you can find some you can
compose them some way in some way that
eventually you'll get a solution but it
depends on your on your Alpha so that's
that's uh the well that makes sense yeah
thanks okay
[Music]
so
um
what time did I start was it health
first I guess so you have five minutes I
have five minutes okay no that's fine
um so how are we gonna do symmetry
breaking then uh well what we're gonna
do is this I told you already we're
gonna pretend to be solving an
optimization problem yeah and what we're
going to be optimizing is like we're
gonna take some lexicographic order
because in the end we want to add these
like leader constraints that say well
lexicographically smaller Solutions are
better
um then the first thing we do is we're
gonna derive the suitable index leader
constraints how you can do this is for
every symmetry separately that you want
to break so for a set of generators or
for other symmetries I don't care where
they come from user might have specified
them we might have detected them
automatically
but we're just gonna for each of them
we're gonna derive this constraint this
is one application of dominance and they
will not interfere so they can all
happen independently which is very nice
and then since we're doing salt solving
we need CNN encodings then we're gonna
take
um let's see another encoding that we
would like to have that expresses this
uh there's a symmetry breaking
constraints
um using
um redundance rules we can introduce the
new variables it needs and using cutting
planes we can actually derive them in
the end exactly this encoding here that
we that we want so take your favorites
enough and going of symmetry breaking
you can derive it from this constraint
it works well not too much overhead well
the Symmetry braking itself there was
almost no override of adding this type
of proof vlogging
um verification of fairy PB
um can be faster still has not yet been
optimized but I mean it's feasible I
think it is at least shows it's feasible
it's not the first time that we're
seeing this these graphs or there's a
factor 10 slow down
um so this is I think a feasible
approach
and um
yeah so as I said just one application
of the dominance through your symmetry
is the witness so the Symmetry that
you're getting is just a witness you
need for a dominance Rule and you're
done basically yeah
um
so the thing you have to prove here is
that you go strictly decreasing in the
order yeah but that will be exactly the
negation of the
um of the constraint you want to add so
this
this all works out nicely there's
basically nothing to prove anymore
and so in a certain sense it's
surprisingly simple because this has
been the technique It Was Out Of Reach
for a while it generalizes well for
arbitrary symmetries for multiple
symmetries everything's independent
um and so the the clue was really
switching to this sort of optimization
perspective and not trying to prove how
you're going to fix up your Solutions
but but showing existence and showing
this indirectly that was really the the
clue to make this work
so to conclude there's many different
symmetry handling methods I promised
some
um some open some open challenges here
um so we now have this fully General
symmetry breaking in very PB it would be
nice to have this working as well in
some extension of divert
um either by by really extending it or
with some sort of dominance or by
figuring out how to encode this
um
this dominance rule
um should be analyzed you can extend the
frag assimilated or not
um apparently there are people who
believe that this might not be so easy
to do
um
we should well
um I showed that it works for or I
should preliminary evidence I claimed at
least that we have a working version
um nothing is published yet there but we
should also check other uh Dynamic
symmetry breaking methods if it works
for them and then um for symmetric
learning also a question is can we
develop this in some sort of framework
that that doesn't know about symmetries
so thank you
yeah um so is this really enabled mostly
by the fact that you can have a witness
that isn't just a solution but is a is a
a renumbering of variables right which
is kind of what a symmetry is anyway so
is that the key element because I mean
then you can just prove that there is at
least one solution which is just as good
as an optimal like right because here
you just encode it this if it was
optimal but honestly all you need is
just at least one no no that's a crucial
thing here is as well uh that the if I
want to break two symmetries so if you
want to break one symmetry that works uh
works perfectly like that so there's no
problem then that's the only thing you
need if you have
um if your symmetry is simple enough but
okay one symmetry is sure if you have
two symmetries uh then when you're
trying to break the second symmetry
you're not going to be able to show that
applying the Symmetry once gives you a
solution to your first simply breaking
constraint and then then you will have
to go apply this one again so it's
really this is going down in the order
that's kind of coordinating between
breaking different symmetries
very good thank you Bart
[Music]
next up is